food is one of the easiest
products over which to say less
regulation is better
you may have never heard of mimolet
cheese but this fancy french import is
at the center of the latest case of the
federal government telling you what you
may or may not eat we went to cheese
teak in alexandria virginia to talk with
jill herbert a cheese monger who's
raising a stink over the latest nanny
state incursion jill what's what's going
on with this cheese well mimolet cheese
is a cheese that has been made for
hundreds of years and has been imported
into the united states freely for
decades mimolet is suddenly in the news
these days because vast quantities of it
are being held in detention by the fda
not allowed into the united states the
fda is concerned that the presence of
cheese mites on the rind of the cheese
would make it dangerous for human
consumption even though the mites have
existed on this cheese and in fact are
intentionally introduced to the rinds of
this cheese for hundreds of years it's
been made the same way without fda
approval this cheese is just going to be
rotting in a holding cell literally
rotting right yes the fda is concerned
because the shipments that they are
seeing of mimolet have exceeded a
guideline or a threshold of the number
of acceptable cheese mites per square
inch on a rind is that guideline
published anywhere to my knowledge it's
not published anywhere it's something
that's result of a survey that they had
done a very long time ago and determined
this magical number of six mites per
square inch and considering these are
microscopic creatures that number is
almost impossible to attain and even to
measure frankly so i mean there's
nothing unique in terms of the mite
situation with mimolet that would say we
got to go after th this is the ring
leader of mite cheese
that is correct um there's no there's no
logical reason because so many cheeses
do have mites it's part of cheese making
it would be like saying we don't want
any cheese with mold on it or any cheese
with bacteria within it
some of the most famous and beloved
cheeses in the world are also might
cover cheeses cheese is like stilton
cheese is like english cheddars american
bandaged wrapped cheddars so these are
going to be cheeses where mites will be
present my concern is sure maybe it's
starting with mimolet but is it going to
continue on to these much more famous
cheeses that people would really um be
concerned about if they disappeared what
are you doing to bring aid and comfort
to mimolet cheese so what we started
doing is through our facebook page
actually we launched an effort to expose
people to the issue in a fun way and we
issued a call to all of our fans and
said hey post photos of yourself
frowning pathetically on our facebook
page and um if you do that we will give
you a free piece of mimolet as a sad
celebration of its departure from the
united states how do you rebut the idea
that you know the fda is keeping you
from eating this memolab for your own
good my argument would be
the research is out there let people
look into what they want to eat if
they're concerned about the safety of a
particular food they shouldn't consume
it people with regard to food especially
really don't like being told what to do
because again to them i think
it's a very clear decision that they can
make for themselves
and i think they really um find it
repugnant almost to have somebody
telling them what what and how much they
should eat of something so
again it's very interesting as with many
causes it has become less about the
actual cheese and more about i want my
choice